good morning it being 10 o'clock we'll
call the finance committee to order and
will welcome the governor of New
Hampshire
all rise
good morning welcome to the finance
committee
yes
yes is this better oh
hot mic hot mic all right well good
morning everybody I thought uh what we
do
um
Lord knows I love a great visual
presentation so I actually I think we're
going to put a few things up on the
screens just to so people get a sense of
of the trends we're not I don't want to
get overly wonky uh about it but
obviously we're here to answer any
questions that that you may have in
terms of what was proposed yesterday and
and all the various aspects of what the
legislature will be taking up so let's
start with something beyond the title
page where are we oh I'm sorry I
apologize so let me first probably start
by introducing James Gary I'm my budget
director
um four budgets four budget directors
and it all seems to be going very well
so
um James has been working on this budget
uh from the really the very beginning
which as a lot of you know starts uh
last summer right when we start putting
out the request for efficiency
um and then that builds into its uh
request for prioritized needs from all
the different departments go through
James and our teams go through with each
of them about priorities then we start
looking at where revenue is coming in uh
what is going to be available in the
current Surplus the end of the fiscal
year 23 as well as uh what opportunities
what lapses might look like and
opportunities will look like a couple
years down the road and I think as a lot
of folks know I really try to take a
long-term Vision on all this stuff as we
deal with the budget and short-term
needs of course but hopefully a
long-term Vision because whatever you do
in the next couple years you want it to
be sustainable right most everything
that we do needs to be sustainable in in
some in some form I'll say that I think
all the I don't want to speak for all
them directly but I'll say every
Department worked really really well
with us
obviously Health and Human Services is
represents 40 or so 40 plus percent of
the state budget it's huge
um as many of you know commissioner
shibanet
has moved on God bless her after
everything she gave the state uh but
commission interim commissioner Weaver
and her team there are exceptional they
really are uh they've been phenomenal to
work with uh Nathan who is the new uh
CFO there came up through the contracts
process so as big and sometimes unwieldy
as that department can seem I will say
we have a very good team there and and I
think we'll be able to answer a lot of
the questions
um both directly and I think again their
presentations to the various committees
as we go through the budget process will
be will be very productive so let's
start with big picture here so what you
see there is our Revenue State revenues
that have come in uh going all the way
back to 2014 just so folks can kind of
get a sense of it this goes out to 2025
so if you look at that that uh bar all
the way at the right those last two are
24 and 25 that's where we are kind of
predicting the state's revenues will go
and what we're really predicting is of
about a half a percent or slight
decrease in state revenues we're not
being overly ambitious about the
revenues we've had all-time high-end
revenues as everybody knows I think
there'll be a stagnation in the economy
nationally it might be a little bump in
the road for us because our economy is
incredibly strong here as everybody
knows businesses continue to come in we
continue to have Workforce challenges as
everybody does that's a tough problem
not a good problem to have but it does
mean you have an incredibly robust
economy with a lot of opportunity and we
can get into how we're dealing with that
but let's just to start on revenues we
effectively are saying revenues are
going to level out and even go down just
a little bit so we're trying to be
conservative if things are better that's
great right if things keep going up a
little bit because we are one of the
strongest economies in the country the
recession doesn't hit the country as
hard as we think that would be
phenomenal and and we'll have a lot of
opportunity at the end but everything we
build here is balanced and everything we
build here is living within those
Revenue projections
um and just as a little bit just before
we go on from that well we can but just
yeah sorry
they're letting me use the computer
that's a dangerous thing
um just to give some perspective in 2022
General funds and education trust funds
exceeded expectations exceeded Plans by
15.4 percent and 23 they exceeded Plans
by 17.4 percent so that's that's the
aggressive nature of our revenues that
we're talking about not being
sustainable and really we shouldn't be
planning on that uh in any way if it
happens that would be great that means
business continues to be out of this
world but I think we're we're trying to
take a more practical measure so we're
seeing we're going to likely level off
from that uh as you'll see most places
do across the country
and we are projecting technically a
surplus a continued Surplus when you
take out all the things that have been
spent through Appropriations through
last year and
um and this year we still expect to have
a surplus to close out this year of 330
million dollars that's after all the
expense the Surplus expenditures that
have already been made
um the totals the total Surplus over
plan is well north of 500 million I
believe correct yes it is it's well
north of 500 million a lot of that has
already been allocated but we still have
300 million dollars in one-time funds
that need to be addressed as part of
this uh next six month period before we
close out the books on 23. okay so let's
look at the revenues I'm not going to go
into oh I'll do it yeah sorry great I'm
not going to go this is just a a very
General Revenue chart I don't expect
everyone to see this but I only put this
this up uh to show you know of the
um
20 or so different 20 plus different
revenue streams we have we really do
look at each one individually uh we
really try to take uh each one as as
they come in terms of their
opportunities
um that's where I we really came up with
the opportunity I think to eliminate the
communications tax uh as we discussed
yesterday this is a tax that is
essentially a tax on everybody's phone
calls the revenues from it continually
decrease because less people are
actually using phone calls they're not
Based on data uh and so as those
revenues decrease we have a lot of a
flexibility there and I just think the
idea that we're going to tax people's
phone calls is uh old Antiquated and
more importantly unnecessary right and I
always go back to that Axiom it's it's
the the citizens money it's not ours if
we don't need as much of it uh give it
back to them in some form so this is uh
one opportunity I think that is
definitely on the table and is being
proposed to eliminate the communications
tax the communication Services tax uh
completely
um moving on from that
so some of the more significant items uh
just in terms of the uh the general fund
the operational items within the general
fund a lot of things that and I don't
mean to be overly repetitive as to what
was discussed yesterday but a lot of
things that we we some of the bigger
ticket items is number one you can have
all the programs and funding in the
world uh but if you don't have the
people behind them it doesn't work uh
and you can look at issues of mental
health or issues of treatment and
recovery so often in these areas we have
the money there's there those a lot of a
lot of mental health organizations in
the state that have plenty of cash right
now but they just can't find people
right and if you don't have the people
you can't Prime up the services same
with the DD Community as well if you
don't have the people you can't find the
service well the state is not immune
from that and so we worked out uh with
the unions a very successful negotiation
with all the different unions that we
have to deal with obviously SEIU is one
of the bigger ones but there are many
unions in the state that we worked
worked out with a 10 raise across the
board uh starting on July 1st and then
another two percent in the second year
of the Buy Union that 10 is as a lot of
you've probably heard by now does
represent the largest single year raise
ever given to the state employees but
this is we're dealing with the largest
inflationary pressures in the last 40 or
50 years so
um it it is para pursue if you will with
uh the needs of the state and and the
Dynamics of our incredibly robust
economy I'll remind folks that when we
did have inflation like this uh back in
the 1980-ish area uh the economy was in
horrible shape right and not only did
they have high inflation but they had an
incredibly weak economy 1980 and 81 were
years a lot of people would economically
like to forget before we really came out
of it in 83 and 84. so uh we have a
strong economy we have the opportunity
uh and so you know obviously that has to
be a major Endeavor as we go forward uh
Medicaid rates uh that we kind of
listened to the legislature on this one
a lot of The Advocates have been talking
to the legislature uh the Senate the
house members everyone came back and
said yeah uh three they recommended a
3.1 percent right three point one
percent across the board so we were able
to build that in we have the opportunity
let's just get it done and make it easy
I think there's opportunities even
beyond what we do there as well and
that's something that we have to look at
I think I you know we assume in this
budget that Medicaid expansion will get
reauthorized as it should I think it
should frankly be reauthorized into
perpetuity but that's really a
legislative decision
um uh but I we we're making that
assumption and it seems like that is all
well on track
um another big thing that we talked
about
uh let me back up a little bit um yeah
let's just jump into oplc why not so
oplc licensure reform right so you know
this is going to be really hard and
contentious it always is in the
legislature I don't think what I'm
proposing is uh is just uh you know
should be rubber stamped by any means
but if you wanted to I'm not going to
complain uh because uh you know as the
governor I always have the right answer
right
um there's a there's a lot here there's
a lot here and a lot to unpack and I do
encourage uh whoever whatever committees
and I'm not even 100 sure that will will
take all of these up it could be pretty
much all the Committees in one way or
the other we'll probably get uh an
earful I'm sure from a lot of different
folks and I get it I get the the idea of
why a lot of this stuff was put in place
in the first place but it has become so
cumbersome so unwieldy I think Lindsay
Courtney over at oplc does a phenomenal
job trying to manage 54 different boards
with 54 different processes with 54
different ways of getting licenses many
of licenses that are Antiquated out of
date and if I can be learned about it
just protectionism and that is the worst
kind of government when you encourage
folks in the private sector to create
rules simply to protect their own
fiefdoms and that's what you have here
in a lot of instances so um it's it's
I'm not picking on any individual
they're all great people with great
businesses it's wonderful but um clearly
a lot of it was designed to make it
difficult for folks from other states to
move their business here or to create
their opportunity here in the fear that
they may take a client or whatever it
might be we are at a point where we want
all the business we can we can get we
want all the private sector we can get
and
frankly whether the economy is strong
where the economy is weak it doesn't
matter in good times and bad our license
plate always says Live Free or Die I
mean that is truly how we have to govern
here we can differ differ as Republicans
and Democrats on different issues of
course but we really have to remember
that this is about individual
opportunities and freedoms and all of
that that sort of thing is very
important
and so when you look at all of it we're
kind of taking a wholesale approach
we're not just asking the same change
for everyone Lindsay and her team went
through each and every single license
each and every single board one by one
some boards you know some of the more
Global things we're trying to do to
start with is we're trying to bring the
size of the boards down
uh if for anything because so many of
these boards will tell us they can't
meet because they don't have a quorum if
the board is too big it's it's much more
difficult to actually get a quorum some
of these boards only will review the
um the licensure uh complaints or
appeals or whatever it is when they have
a quorum and when they all meet and it's
just becoming too difficult so the
entire process gets held up and then we
we get complaints well New Hampshire's
bureaucracy is slowing things down it's
not so much the bureaucracy slowing
things down is that our system is is
really isn't designed to be as
successful as it could be in those areas
so
um director Courtney went through and
really looked at each one of these I'm
sure she'll come in and testify on all
of them uh about the house and why some
move to more an advisory role some
licenses we get rid of altogether I mean
the the obvious uh example I will give
is that technically I never say the
internet in tournament license I'm not
going to say that word right
what is it
itinerant yeah technically look you need
a license to basically go door to door
right so are we going to start locking
up all the Girl Scouts right come on so
nobody it's like let's just get that
thing that kind of thing off the book
The Hawkers and Peddler's license I
please you want to Hawk something you
want to Pedal something first you can
start by telling me the difference I'm
sure there's some dictionary difference
in there but the point is some of this
is really Antiquated it's right that was
a run out of the Secretary of State's
office so my point there is that there's
a real opportunity not just to go after
the the cosmetologist not just to go
after the medical review board not just
to go after this group or that group but
really take them as a whole because it
is becoming so a cumbersome and unwieldy
and now that we have a process by which
everything is flowing through oplc it's
a great opportunity to really provide
oversight uh and Synergy uh between all
those different processes the other
thing is and it doesn't take away the
authority it's not so much taking
Authority away from these boards um it's
it's allowing the administrative
processes that oplc has to do to work on
on a more streamlined basis of course
and the boards have to have a voice they
have to have that representation but uh
too often you have boards that are that
if I may I don't want to say I'm more
that take on a much more serious role
than others in terms of the medical
review board right the nursing licensing
board these are these are boards that if
you don't get it right lives are at risk
and we've seen that not go well in this
state in the past couple years
um we've read some of these examples in
the paper where the boards aren't
meeting where things aren't being
reviewed where things aren't transparent
our peels aren't being processed you
can't we can't do that anymore we really
have to kind of take a wholesale
approach to oplc in the boards and and
hopefully make some changes and I'm sure
there'll be a lot of other really good
ideas thrown into the mix but it's
something that as a state
um getting rid of this 14 unnecessary
boards
um 34 different licenses types that
we're recommending to get rid of we have
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
licenses in the State uh in terms of the
private sector we are one of the most
over-regulated states in the country so
let's kind of start there and see if we
can't chip away and work back and create
some efficiencies through that process
we put some significant uh increases for
UNH here both in terms of their
operational requests as well as the
community college so
I gotta say uh without you know
fanboying too much I think president
Dean has done a fantastic job on a
variety of levels so president Dean has
come in one of the first things he did
is he hired an outside consultant this
group came in and gave him a huge report
on potential efficiencies streamlining
processes cutting of costs in the
University system and they didn't put to
their credit they didn't put the report
in a drawer they really took action on a
lot of it they did the buyout Provisions
with a lot of their um uh uh faculty and
that has saved them millions in tens and
tens of millions of dollars Catherine
preventers over there our former State
Treasurer she's got a great handle on
the finances I think there's a very
solid team there when you look at the
cost uh the not the just the tuition
rate we know tuition's High always has
been and unfortunately likely will be in
the future but the fact that they have
Frozen tuition now for five straight
years is a testament to their management
the fact that they've put these
efficiencies in they've cut their costs
and still maintain some of the lowest
costs around pursue student I think is
is absolutely terrific in terms of what
they've done so we've met there when we
go through as to the hows and whys if
they want some operational increase from
the legislature I agree with it
wholeheartedly I think there's some
other Investments we can make there and
I will talk about that on the capital
and uh Surplus side same with the
Community College I think they've done
they've done very very well over there
we're never going to get our tuition
rates you know this is New England New
England is always going to have a fairly
High tuition rates unfortunately Vermont
has I think even higher rates than us
but like I said the fact that they've
Frozen these rates for five straight
years now I think is a great Testament
to their management and that's why again
we I feel very confident moving forward
with some of the increases they're
looking for in their operational funds
you know something that didn't get
talked about too much but I just threw
in here at the last second we need a new
Men's prison
um desperately we saw what happened with
the women's prison years ago when we
left it uh too long we got sued and
probably rightfully so we were getting
sued because it was in deplorable
condition and it wasn't easy but we
worked hard and we got that that new
facility done and it's been running
fantastic since the Men's prison is
really right on the edge now this is not
a small price tag you are talking
minimum 350 to 450 million dollars so
this is a long-term investment the state
is going to make what I am proposing
um how the state wants to look at
bonding that down the road I think
that's a bigger discussion but what I'm
proposing is is it 40 or 50. 40 plus 10
right yeah 50 million dollars total
uh 40 out of the operational side of the
budget 10 out of the is it the Surplus
side
um 50 million dollars total to really
set a marker to start everything from
architectural design planning
feasibility uh what the size should be
get all those things that have to happen
and get the ball moving how it would be
laid out how it would be done and then I
proposed that's about the first 10
million and then there's another 40
million in this budget that kind of sets
a Mark or maybe even starts on on
building phase one I think we have to if
you will put a shovel in the ground to
make sure that we're committing all the
way through and then again the
Consultants can come in and figure out
how best to design and make this
efficient but this is a very very major
infrastructure project that the state
has to take on cannot really avoid it
much longer and um we had we have funds
right now right we have the opportunity
so whether it's looking at bonding for
the long term which again you got to
look at rates and what that would be but
taking some of our our money today that
we do have flexibility with putting that
marker in the ground getting the project
moving knowing it it could be a four or
five six to your Endeavor for the state
to get us where we really need to be and
the other piece I'll throw out here and
we can take questions on any of it but
um well just like look like I said
virtually every state agency so we go
through this efficiency budget which is
what do you need to keep your your
department running minimally and then we
kind of look at all the additional
add-ons where we can find efficiencies
spending a lot of times I challenge my
departments to say look tell me where
you can spend more one-time money so we
need less employees right where we we
have a lack of employees or a lack of
service maybe we invest in a technology
we invest in a process we invest in
something with this one these one-time
funds we have uh to take some of the I
mean our workers are are putting
everything they got into their days
there's just no doubt about that we have
staff in certain departments for staff
that are doing the work of of 10 and so
again if we can make an investment there
knowing that we might get four staff to
six or seven but we might not be able to
get to to full capacity maybe there's
Investments we can make in one-time
Technologies are opportunities and we
really challenge them with that when we
look at their prior prioritized needs
but obviously the prioritized needs come
in a variety of different forms
um so that's that's some of the bigger
I'll just say the bigger ticket items on
the operational side
Let's Talk education so this is this is
a little complicated but and I'm going
to do my best because Lord knows I want
to run over there and point at
everything I need one of those virtual
pointers
what I'm showing here is the very
complicated formula that we use to fund
education
so phase one what you see at the top is
what we call the left side of the form
and I'm telling I know a lot of you guys
understand this so so bear with me but
just as a review right we could all use
a little review sometimes you know the
left side of the formula is everything
you see in blue and that's our number of
students times the base adequacy we give
per student the number of special ed
kids uh with with their dollars the
number of ESL kids we have a reading
Grant in there we have free and reduced
lunch in there those are the five big
pieces with fixed amounts that we give
to each School based on on the number of
students that they have
we then do the swept calculation and
that's what you see in the black on the
second row we take the total calculated
cost of an adequate education we take
out the Statewide property tax most
towns are at least a large variety of
towns have have no change and they're
fine they basically hold on to their
their their local property taxes a lot
of towns need some additional funds and
we put some more money in through the
the swept process and then you get to
the bottom and obviously I'm going
pretty quick through this then you get
to the bottom which is the right side of
the formula this is where the
legislature over the past 16 years I
call this the Band-Aids we just keep
band-aiding on fixes right and and each
band-aid's a little different each
Band-Aid is a little more complicated
than the last and and this is where I
think there's a lot of opportunity to
simplify
because when what I found and again I've
I'm I've gone through this four times
now and what I found is that whenever we
talk about this the solution is another
Band-Aid without really looking at how
the other Band-Aids are working are not
working right you know what and it's
work it's hard I get it none of this is
easy and and we're going to get to the
concept of spreadsheet Wars in a minute
and you guys are going to have some fun
with that I'm sure but
this is my fundamental problem is that
not only is it an overly complicated
system equation I mean look at all the
different variables that go into that
then you add in you know normalized
property valuations and all of that sort
of thing that are buried in each of
those some of those little pieces to ask
anyone outside of Concord to understand
appreciate or have valuable input into
how this could be better is almost
impossible I mean it's really almost too
much to ask anyone you know
well I was going to pick on Bill
ardinger you know and people like that
really really amazingly smart people
that spend all their days on this stuff
get it but very few others very few
others really understand it so
conceptually I said well let's simplify
the other issue we really have
I don't know if we put it in here I
don't know we didn't okay let me back up
the other issue that we really have is
for the first time and this is the
fundamental difference why I think the
opportunity today is so critical on on
the education formula we have never had
an education trust fund Surplus like
this
I mean in some years we have five
million or 10 million dollars do you
know what the numbers today technically
170 million dollars that if we do
nothing is going to just keep growing
right so that sir and that Surplus can
really only be spent on education right
you can't use it for anything else and
nor should you so it's not just the
opportunity to hopefully challenge
ourselves to make some bigger changes
and and and find some Simplicity but the
need because otherwise you're going to
have all this money just sitting on the
sidelines and that's a that's a huge
waste and missed opportunity okay so let
me take you through this a little bit
oh what would I do oh no I'm going
backwards hold on there we go so what
you'll see I do with the first piece
here is we take the base amount that we
give right now our base Aid amount which
is right now off the top my head I think
is 38.66 and I start just in year one
right away we move that to 4 700 that's
about a 24 increase just on day one
uh no that's with the CPI piece put in
at the end of the biennium right yes
yeah so the 40s sorry I'm gonna let
let's reverse all that
I take the base amount I move it to 4
700 that's true that's about a 21.5
increase to be fair
the free and reduced lunch amount move
that to 2500 right that's up in the
upper 20 so I'll explain why these
numbers are a little different
the other big piece here and why the
numbers you're seeing are a little
different is that what I realized and I
have to admit I didn't know this is how
CPI and the inflationary aspects of
those amounts was calculated we take a
three-year average of inflation
but we only allocate it every other year
so but inflation is cumulative if you're
not adding it in every year
your differential between the real costs
and what your funding gets bigger and
bigger and bigger so I think a
fundamental change that I I'm hoping
everybody has to agree with is we're
going to account for some sort of
inflationary piece every single year
because otherwise you're just giving
half of you're just accounting for half
of the inflationary costs each biennium
and your Delta is going to continue
getting bigger and you're going to keep
them going to have to come back for
Band-Aids so the 24 and 30 percent
you're seeing there is when you put in
two percent inflation after the first
year you get to a 24 you get a little
more you get to like 48
34 or something and then each year after
that you just keep the two percent
moving forward we can do that now I get
maybe years ago you couldn't do that but
we've built this out over 10 and 20
years and the model still keeps plenty
of cash at the end of the day right
there's still a good Financial cushion
so we can build in inflationary
increases the right way the appropriate
way the Fairway and still not overly
drain the trust fund which I think is an
exciting opportunity so that's why by
the end of this biennium you'd have a 24
and a 30 increase in each of those two
core pieces and that does a whole
variety of things people have been
screaming about trying to do that for
years we have lost major lawsuits that
are being held up because we don't do
enough on that and right by that so I
that's a that's step one of the huge
opportunity uh that we have we also by
doing that we don't need I think it's
the reading piece comes out right
reading this reading number that was
added in a third grade reading number
that was added in years ago uh we we
we're taking that out because that was
kind of the left side of the equation
Band-Aid that was put in years ago and
this kind of takes care of that into
perpetuity so it simplifies the left
side of the formula then you got to go
through your swept calculation and what
we call phase two there uh the same way
you always would but now we get to phase
three
so what we did have let me show you what
phase three was right you had all these
pieces
and now we're moving here so
we have this is the right side of the
formula is what drives me crazy
the right side of the formula as many
know but many may not is is really where
we say well this formula that was
created in 2006 uh we're never going to
move it the right side of the formula
creates stable it normally has
stabilization
uh and a couple other pieces in it that
are based off attendance of 2006.
it's based off property values of 2006.
so let's the thing that boggles my mind
is imagine when they created this
formula in 2006 they said we're going to
base it on attendance and property
evaluation of 1990.
that would be absurd right that'd be
great why would you ever do that that's
literally what we're doing
so let's start there that that's a
really really bad idea things change
when why do the budget for the rest of
the state departments change we have to
move money we have to make adjustments
we change our priorities we change our
needs we look at fluctuate you have to
make those changes it doesn't mean that
everyone is going to keep getting
everything they want into perpetuity but
right now you are set up to do that and
that is unfair it's unequitable it's
it's just a disastrous idea on many
levels I get that it was never easy to
do before but now we have this huge
education trust fund balance I'm going
to keep going back to that things are
really really different now
so what do I do I take all the pieces of
the right side of the formula and I
basically move them we you did last year
something called extraordinary needs so
I said okay let's keep that one right
let's keep one of these pieces because
that was really designed again as it
should be to make sure that towns that
have lower property valuations if you
will the poor or towns that have you
know that don't have the property values
and property tax income that other towns
might have I have a bigger bite at the
Apple and that's fair I think that's
appropriate you should do that let's
just keep it to one one formula though
right that's kind of what I'm doing you
guys can jiggle with that and figure out
what the formula should be I think
extraordinary needs that you did last
year was a really good one so I picked
that one
now should we some of these towns may
lose some dollars that's obvious
um should we cut them off tomorrow no
this I don't do that I do create a hold
harmless provision
so I create a whole harmless provision
and at about seven it starts at about 78
million dollars right and then we slowly
every two years you ratchet it down I my
plan is to ratchet it down 20 percent
every two years over the next ten
hold harmless will go down 20 percent
extraordinary needs each of those years
goes up fifty percent so we're kind of
moving some of those whole harmless
dollars into the extraordinary needs so
the theory is at the end of ten years
you get to a point where you just have
the left side of the formula and
extraordinary needs on the right side
and that way it's simpler for the
legislature to say look when we want to
help a poorer town or we want we're
going to do it through the extraordinary
needs piece not just keep adding 100
more pieces onto it and complicate it
I know this is a lot I do trust me I've
spent three months on it myself and I've
been knee-deep in it so I don't expect
it all to be super simple and obvious in
just one presentation but that's
fundamentally what I'm trying to get
here we have to do something for lower
income towns but to say that we're just
going to keep I mean there are towns
with 30 more than 30 percent less kids
today than in 2006. I I get it they're
going to likely get some less money
they'll be they'll get this hold
harmless provision in a major way and
they'll get some extraordinary needs
money and that'll keep growing for them
that'll be great but to say that we're
never going to change that is just
I it's it's obvious right that that
obviously has to change
let's go back to 1990. why 2006 why
don't we go back to the population and
property valuations of 19 see what
happens we've just kind of picked this
arbitrary year unintentionally but but
that's kind of where We've Ended up so
hopefully we're willing to kind of take
on that challenge and and uh and and
move forward with it what are some of
the bigger pieces I'm missing here James
what happens oh yeah so what you're
seeing here is so let me back up so in
the first year you have on the bottom I
know you can't read it that's the the um
the extraordinary needs is in the middle
the hold harmless provision is on the
right
um what's this what is that
it's just extraordinary needs and hold
harmless and what I'm showing here is
Boom we go to basically extraordinary
needs over the over the long term so
again it's just that's just showing the
simplification and again I think the
opportunity here is with that if you get
back to a I just do I did a two percent
number on inflation it's actually
probably too high but historically over
the past 40 years inflation is two
percent I know we're in this very
bizarre time right now but two percent
is really historically where you want is
where inflation is maybe 1.5 percent but
with including that every single year
that's the opportunity to not to take
care of the this left side of the
formula and again with the huge increase
we're doing on free and reduced lunch
those that's typically a marker of of
the poorer towns and so they're going to
get huge increases per student on all of
those areas in a fair and Equitable way
and so that again also helps them helps
make sure that they are they're kept
whole so to say oh so here's a here's
the graph I was showing this is the
balance of the of the education trust
fund so you can see what we're dealing
with here right so in the third bar from
the right is 2023 that's where we are
today now over time we we take down the
uh trust fund balance a little bit in 24
and a little bit in 25. there's a huge
opportunity to do school building Aid I
take 75 million out of this trust fund
balance for school building Aid and
while we don't bring this all the way
out to 2033 or 2034 there is still a
positive Surplus in this here's
something else I'm going to add on that
I haven't brought to anybody's attention
yet I know the legislature is strongly
looking at doing automatic enrollment of
free and reduced lunch for Medicaid for
families on Medicaid
you can debate whether you should or
shouldn't do that my budget builds in
the opportunity that if you do that it's
all good it's I've created a cushion in
here to financially sustain that without
having to mess with anything I'm kind of
assuming that you may do that I don't
know if you will but I'm assuming that
that may come to the table I know
there's a lot of support bipartisan
support for it so if it happens it's a
big number 30 plus million a year right
sorry Mark's here he's the brains behind
all this from uh from uh doe um it's
about 30 plus million a year if you
decided to automatically enroll every
Medicaid kid into free and reduced lunch
some states do it some don't we can we
can handle it without without messing
with anything so I've built that cushion
in there for you
um
and here's just a number I sure brought
this is just this is just total
Appropriations to Public Schools all
albums are all yeah all schools right
this is all of our Appropriations we
give to all schools and again this is
done by biennium so the the bar you see
on the right is what I'm proposing
because we can I again we still have
money left in the bank even after making
these increases because of the
transformative decrease in in child
population which will likely decrease
one about one percent a year for the
next 10 years that's going to continue
unfortunately this next generation is
having less kids later in life that's a
fundamental Dynamic
um so we just have to appreciate that I
think in in the modeling as as we go
forward and that's why again some towns
are going to continue to oh I should say
again why we need to adjust this now
because that population differential is
going to keep growing for some towns
even above and beyond Norms some
sometimes have gone up 30 population of
students sometimes have gone down
Windham is a good example I think
they're up like 30 35 percent you know
and obviously we'd all know the story of
Berlin it's it's boy they go through a
lot of troubles I have a lot of empathy
and sympathy I spent a lot of time up
there but they're down 35 percent you
know there's other towns too it's not
just them so you just have to we have to
understand those are just very different
Dynamics My Hope as an aside is that a
lot of these districts will be
incentivized through the school building
Aid to consolidate
I mean that's what you need in a lot of
instances not every instance but in a
lot of instances
um you know Berlin High School is
probably a good example I'm not I'm not
picking on Berlin at all I think it's a
huge opportunity to say hey let's make
an investment and find a way to put
Gorham and Berlin together or something
like that there's probably 10 other
similar examples across the state if a
town wants to retain their school that's
fine if they you know want that
individuality I think it's awesome I
live in a really tiny town of newfields
1500 people I hope we don't lose our
elementary school if we choose not to
consolidate with somebody else but again
the fact that everyone else is going to
pay for that choice at an exorbitant
amount you have to decide whether that's
really fair or not right so hopefully we
can incentivize that with some of the
one-time funds that we have and there I
think there'll be some very good and
exciting opportunities uh in in a lot of
different circumstances across the state
um okay so this uh probably so this is
just another chart kind of showing
um the 3866 on the left and that's the
top bar goes to 4 700 1933 that's what
we do for free and reduce lunch today
that'll move to 2500 on on day one and
then again go up two percent every year
um we extreme increase the extraordinary
needs grants every year by 50 we start
with a big amount of about 80 million on
on whole on a hold harmless provision
every two years it just ticks down uh 20
so you have a 10-year slow rollout so it
gives to towns plenty of time to make
any adjustments or unnecessary until we
get back to a more normalized formula
and then the big piece on the bottom is
that CPI adjustment which I think is so
critical I apologize for being
repetitive I just know there's a lot of
pieces here and I know I I talk fast my
dad will watch this online and he'll
tell me you're talking too fast you
gotta slow down dummy I get that one
every day in a text
um
and that's again I'm not going to repeat
this as kind of uh the stuff that we
just talked about
um oh so people always ask about charter
schools and efas right so my budget does
propose uh it effectively doubles the
amount of opportunity into education
Freedom accounts we thought a few
hundred families would take advantage
thousands of families are taking an
advantage it's just it's so popular more
people want in huge opportunity we're
doing it right
um and and so again that appropriation
gets uh substantial I think commissioner
adelbroot was the one that proposed
moving uh for certain subsets uh of
students maybe they they're within the
DD Community or their their folks are
veterans or there's a whole subset of
um exemptions if you will that
commissioner Ada put together and
allowing them up to 500 percent of the
federal poverty level
um these are students that are just in
extraordinary circumstances for one way
or another and kind of opening up the
the opportunity there I think is huge
but by moving these base amounts you're
also increasing the amount you sent to
Charter Schools too right and and
that'll be great and I think I'm looking
at representative Moody she's she's
Moody she's got a great bill out there
as well that'll also provide a lot a lot
of opportunity but there's Financial
opportunity there for all of this right
the thing I like about this is everybody
no one's going to be thrilled but
everybody gets a win everybody gets a
win
um whether it's it's a dealing with the
left side of the formula that a lot of
I'll just say a lot of Democrats have
come to me and asked to really challenge
ourselves on that side or the
simplifying the right side or making
sure Charter Schools or efas get get can
can grow appropriately and be more
equitably funded that's all there it's
all there or or
School building Aid where's Michael
did he leave Miss Cahill oh he left me
with the sheet Michael okay Hill calling
me and once a week asking me for a
school building Aid God bless him I gave
my text number back in 2015. he doesn't
let me forget it but he but it's good
and he and he he has some very good
ideas and again having that 75 million
dollars is still being able to fulfill
what we've already obligated but also
adding another 75 million in there is a
huge opportunity so even Michael Cahill
might be happy about this which is
exciting okay
the last thing I'm going to go through
and I know I'm going along I tend to be
kind of in in the weeds uh some of the
bigger some some folks are asking just
about some of the bigger Capital
highlights now the capital one-time
money comes in both the Surplus which is
historical hundreds of millions in the
Surplus as well as the 125 million in
the rainy day uh in the capital budget
itself so the capital budget the
traditional capital budget some of the
bigger items you see uh on the left
there and more the Surplus bigger items
on the right so we have the liquor
stores that have to get rebuilt in
Hampton when you do that you're going to
create so much more Revenue it's going
to be fantastic every time we rebuild
one of these stores we we end up making
lots more money and it's it's a
no-brainer huge win uh when when we
again sell the property and then uh can
actually rebuild that store uh edu
department of education's building as a
lot of you know was completely infested
within in asbestos last year had to get
completely redone and we need to buy the
new building the Rochester courthouse uh
there's a um if you've been in the
courthouse
you understand right
uh these are 8.5 million allocated to
the National Guard
um the Clean Water the clean drinking
water clean water and the drinking water
matches are both Federal matches that
allow us to pull down a lot of federal
funds on the left-hand side of that
sometimes we shortchange that but we
just don't have to this year so
um you know that's money that's been
allocated to the state so I say we go
get it on the Surplus side mmis that's
the Medicaid management system very
expensive system this is the next phase
of it uh to over 20 million dollars it
really has to get done to manage the 150
000 plus 180 000 plus individuals within
Medicaid doj is going to have their new
building uh a few folks in this room are
going to have wonderful new parking
spots uh that's in there at the 15
million dollar amount that we were given
uh that the 10 million for the new Men's
prison that's that initial 10 million to
at least over the next year or two to do
the initial design invest in h in the
housing right so another 30 million into
invest in age 25 million into the New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
those programs are just rolling out very
very well to actually put shovels in the
ground build bricks and mortar get
actual more housing up so we want to
continue those programs the crypto
interoperability lab it's only one and a
half million but that's a very new thing
if any of you were paying attention to
the crypto discussions digital assets
this really makes sure that we're
protecting ourselves in a variety of
different ways within the state and it
goes without if you've read the news at
all about all the different
controversies surrounding crypto digital
assets blockchain there's huge
opportunity there but it does need a
regulatory framework and this crypto
interoperability lab it's very low money
for one and a half million to at least
kind of put us at the Forefront very few
states have anything like this I don't
know if any do actually but it would
really put us at the Forefront in terms
of understanding the issues protecting
us uh making sure look there's no doubt
uh there are there there were Russian
entities trying to launder their money
through crypto here in the United States
right so understanding how that system
works and making sure we're provide
providing the right guidelines so it's
not happening here year I think is very
very important and you know a fun little
project but it's amazing but it's
important it's it's not a throwaway by
any means I am proposing eight million
dollars to UNH hockey and people say
what are you doing with UNH hockey look
that's a D1 team but they don't have a
D1 facility we don't have a lot of that
stuff in in the state right we are not
known for our big sports but we do love
our hockey we have a great hockey team
we have an incredible program over there
um but the place does need something
else so I've been meeting with folks
this is about 25 of the cost they're
going to raise a lot of it on the
private sector they're going to put some
money money in themselves and they've
asked the state to make an allocation
which I I think I think is very
important the new way that you know we
want our we want the UNH system they're
making the right Investments they're
creating the right efficiencies and you
want to you need you need a brand right
when you look at what kids look at to
whether they're going to not just go
play hockey at a university but the
pride behind teams and all that sort of
thing it's really important and UNH
hockey has been phenomenal over the
years uh waning a little bit and it's
hard to recruit new players and all of
that and the facility probably needs
some major upgrade in the near future
anyway so we have the money Now's the
Time so I threw it in there
um for all those who are like UNH hockey
so that was super fast uh a lot but
super fast we can open up for questions
you can kick me right out of here
whatever you guys like but I think
there's a huge opportunity here lots of
money to go around
um it's it's better than having to cut
ten percent right and some of you were
in those days uh those um those points
back in the day but spending spending
more money than you expected to have is
also a kind of a challenging
responsibility too making sure that you
kind of get that right and hopefully
plan for the future
okay all right good I didn't get too
much wrong there so I'll turn it back
over to you Mr chairman thank you
thank you for your presentation Governor
I'm happy to say that within the
experience of this committee there's
over 100 years in performing our
constitutional duty to create the state
budget and I'm also happy to say that
the legislative budget assistant
has over 100 years experience also
collectively so I'm happy that you're
ready to answer a few questions and
first representative Edwards and then
representative McGuire another questions
thank you Mr chair and uh welcome
Governor uh I I want to start by
thanking you for signing the YDC Bill
yesterday that was tremendous
coordination cooperation with the Senate
and the and you so so that's great uh
and in that theme I I have an
observation before my question and that
is uh with all the legislative
discussion in the last week or two I'm
concerned that as I look at your capital
and one-time money I don't see anything
for a YDC replacement and and I think
that's going to be a topic because it
feels like we're running the clock out
on the ARP money and forcing it into
General funds by delay and I I just want
to make sure that everyone is aware
there's a bill there that absolutely so
I appreciate that let me harp right on
can I can I get to my question oh I'm
sorry
that was that was the observation that
was just the observation so so
um I have constituents who are going to
come to me and say this is a great
budget but I'm not seeing any Bill
payers or spending reductions I'm seeing
increases across the board and uh and
maybe we can afford that uh you think we
do but uh there's some concern that as
we go ahead and fund the state at the
level that we want to fund the state
we're crowding out the possibility of
resources being used in the private
sector so so there's there's kind of an
economic uh reason in shortages like we
have to have less government and more
private sector it's a strategy and I'm
just curious to what extent you know
where you are on that part of the
strategy yeah well look I I we cut taxes
I got rid of it Tire tax you want to cut
more taxes Lord knows I'm not going to
say no to that
um the the fact is our economy is
incredibly strong right the dollars keep
coming in without a doubt so uh I I
you're talking to the number I'm very
proud I'm ranked the number one well I'm
now number two most fiscally responsible
governor in the country Kim Reynolds
beat me out this year I used to be
number one so no you're talking to
fiscal Hawk you want to cut cut the size
of government and streamline absolutely
but our economy is really strong we're
not we're not asking for a single extra
dollar that is we're sending more back
to schools than every report we're kind
of reallocating the right way so if you
want to cut more that that's okay I tell
me where to cut it though I mean there's
there's just
I think we've done a great job in years
one and two not so much in three and
four but maybe in years five and six of
this Administration have constantly
cutting out the bureaucracy
um the big the big reason we have a lot
a lot of flexibility and the big reason
you have a surplus the prime one of the
primary reasons is we don't have staff
right there some of these lapses are so
huge because we haven't had a lot of
Staff that's not necessarily a very good
way to to do things so I would just
caution that some of the excess money
today isn't necessarily access tomorrow
right and if I kept assuming you know
we're increasing revenues five six
percent or fifteen percent like we've
had no I'm saying our revenues are going
down all right so but we've just managed
really really well
um and we've created much more efficient
systems and by that I mean
you know we we try to put more of the
treatment and Recovery local not just in
Manchester or Concord we try to put more
of them more on the mental health
services local the emergency teams out
there we don't want folks to have to
come to New Hampshire hospital and again
that actually it costs a little more up
front which we did a few years ago but
the long-term efficiencies of the system
get much better you have less recidivism
into the systems and all all of those
sorts of things so um just I do want to
go back to YDC though right that's
really important so I did sign that bill
yesterday I was also very frustrated
that I only got that we only extended
the date that's fine you absolutely need
money in there I'm holding back enough
arpa money arpa money is ready to go and
we would move it through tomorrow and
that's what the the expectation was if
the legislature doesn't do it we can
still move the arpa money forward it
doesn't necessarily have to come
directly out of the budget so I have a
couple different pots we can pull from
on a moment's notice as do you uh to
actually move that forward and that has
to happen by the end of 24 you
absolutely need a new facility in this
state some of those kids are are
dangerous to themselves they're
dangerous to others we have a system now
that is not just lock them up we don't
do that anymore that's the awesome part
of this we have a system that really is
programmatic and creates Whole Health
services around those kids around those
individuals to get them back on track
but you don't just say we're kids that
are dangerous to themselves and others
we're just going to send home that's
that's not that's dangerous it's
dangerous so I think most people
actually understand that and you you do
have to move forward in in some way so
I'd hopefully I would hope that they
they both the legislature both authorize
the construction and then move forward
whether it's with the Opera money or
surplus funds here this budget still
allocates 180 million dollars to the
rainy day fund right about 90 or so at
the end of this year and another 80 or
90 or so at the end of 25. so there's a
lot a lot of flexibility to play with
here
um even assuming revenues are coming
down so that's about as constraint as as
I think we could practically make it in
the hopes that we were finally able to
bring our vacancy rate from 20 maybe
down to 10 or 12 percent
thank you yeah representative McGuire
has a question thank you Mr chairman
thank you governor for coming there's a
lot of fantastic stuff here particularly
licensing and adequacy in my opinion
um let me ask you about school building
Aid so the way that program has worked
in the past is every year there's
there's one two three four winners
there's about 12 losers and there's a
hundreds that don't even bother to apply
right because you know it's very chunky
is my point would it be better to
perhaps inadequacy have have a small
payment that's that's a capital payment
you know that's that's so much per year
because every kid's going to need school
at some point that that would be a kind
of a capital pay down or something per
year rather than having a special
program that touches you and touches you
but not to everybody yeah so you know my
budget allocates the 75 million
um I gotta be honest however you you
guys want to do it is is fine I mean you
guys are the voice of the people you're
hearing what's happening out there I
will tell you I think similarly my
feeling is
even though the existing structure of
school building Aid does I think split
it out into thirds or something like
that it looks at the size of schools it
doesn't the challenge with that is I
think that's great because I think small
schools are getting left behind this is
going to be the end of my thesis is
small school small districts get left
behind they're allocated a certain
portion of the money but a lot of these
districts don't have the teams at a
Manchester or Dover or or Portsmouth or
Plymouth desert I'm just kind of picking
big towns that you know they have kind
of the teams and the experts they know
how to go after the money they can get
the Architects on the line they can get
they can get it faster right
um so any process that allows smaller
towns to have better access to these
Capital funds I I'm all for
um but I I got to be honest I'm going to
really defer to you guys how you want to
divide it up I'm just kind of saying
look we have at least 75 million to put
into school building Aid whether it's
just plowing it into the old formula or
coming up with a different way I'm a bit
agnostic on it I would just hope and ask
that you try to create a system that
allows smaller town to have as big of a
bite of the apple as the the big guys
representative Heath for a question
thank you Mr chair and Governor thank
you for putting support behind education
and I also want to thank you for your
comments about Medicaid direct
certification I think that's a win-win
for our state and I'm certainly hoping
that this body will go along with that I
I just think it uh means a lot to so
many
um couple of questions oh but one other
thing what about football at UNH uh I'm
sorry I don't know I went to a football
game but that Stadium looked pretty darn
good to me I couldn't help it
um my to my real questions
um does the savings from phasing out
stabilization grants cover the proposed
increase in adequacy Aid and I think you
kind of touched on that and I'll just
keep going by other questions and in
terms of the um accountability
requirements for the extraordinary needs
grants um are you going to continue that
requirement and then finally how
confident are you that the education
trust fund can support the proposed
changes with the business business tax
cuts that are in place and the interest
in dividends phase out sure great all
great questions so the quick answer is
in taking all the right side of the
formula stuff
um a good portion is still kept into the
whole harmless and extraordinary needs
Provisions that we remain on the right
side and a good portion goes back to the
left side of the formula to to more
adequately account for for you know
existing students as opposed to students
of 2006.
um yeah it's all very financially it all
works out fiscally it all absolutely
works out we've run this out 10 to 20
years and there's still plenty of money
in the trust fund and as I said even if
you made a big switch like doing the the
free and reduced lunch for every
automatic enrollment of every Medicaid
kid 30 million dollars we can handle
that too I didn't put it in my budget
that's kind of I think there's a bill
out there to do that but that initiative
it will before to pass nothing nothing
could change and we're still financially
stable uh there's another question there
sorry uh the taxes
uh yeah that our tax base is very
healthy yeah I mean I assume revenues go
down and this all still works
um you know because the way that you the
legislature in the past has set up a
certain dedicated portion going to the
education trust fund
um yeah it's still it's still there so
it it all plays out based on the the
revenues not just for next year but for
the next 10 or more goes out beyond that
yeah
representative papovichi Miller for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you governor for taking the questions
um frankly this is the one committee
where it's totally safe to get into the
weeds yeah yeah the finance committee
um one particular uh area that wasn't
covered in the highlights is
um you know our unfunded liability for
the retirement system I just wanted to
hear your thoughts on
how you know you would see us handling
and catching up on that issue great
question so uh as you as many as you all
know I think significant changes were
made to the system back in around 2011.
it's a roughly a 30-year plan if you
will that was designed to close the the
extreme uh liability uh there's a lot of
variables that go into that
um there is flexibility here yeah a lot
of folks have said look let's just take
some of the Surplus and dump it into the
Corpus and if you wanted to do that you
could we have a lot of surplus we have a
you know it's part of that rainy day
trust fund if you say we want to take 50
million even 100 million I'm not
necessarily recommending that but I
would leave that to you huge opportunity
to just eat down on that Corpus we made
huge changes to the retirement not huge
but very significant changes to the
retirement system both in terms of the
cost of living adjustment we made a few
years ago what we did last year with a
few pieces I think there's some bills
before you that they're really
aggressive I think they're like 50 to
100 million dollar bills to basically
undo everything that was done back in
2011. I don't necessarily think that's a
good good idea but this liability is
very real you bring up an incredibly
good point we I kept a lot of
flexibility in there in case you wanted
to on the on the one-time money side if
you want to eat down on that Corpus yeah
which would be a good idea
representative wellner for a question
thank you
um thank you for being here Governor
um I know that you mentioned that
there's going to be a three percent rate
increase for the Medicaid providers is
that across the board and I mean I I
know you I all of us have been hearing
from the Medicaid providers that
um
there some some of them feel that their
need is much greater than the three
percent and have you uh given any
thought to that yeah so let me you know
when I went off when we did significant
rate increases a few years ago I thought
that across the board approach was a bad
idea I actually still think it's not
great but I know that that's probably
where the legislature wants to go there
are Medicaid providers
that need 12 increases there are
Medicaid providers that are four or five
percent over Market
I mean why why would we give them an
increase so I tried to ask the
legislature a few years ago to look at
it Case by case uh discipline by
discipline to really make sure we're
giving more to those that needed more
and less to those that needed less right
when you compare it to Market and to
what the workforce demand needs are I
did the 3.1 percent across the board as
because well I don't think it's the best
idea I thought it was the most palatable
to the legislature but if you want to go
more specific I am all with that because
there are providers that need more than
three percent I am the first to
acknowledge that I just put it in there
because it sounded like that's where the
legislature was going and I was more
than anything trying to keep it
simplistic as an aspect of the budget
but I can tell you there are providers
that get a little too much and providers
get get way too little
yeah but I know that's hard nobody when
we tried to do it last time well I don't
want to give them six percent in him
only two percent but I and my argument
was but he only needs six percent and he
only needs two percent like he needs six
and he needs to do I allocate the money
to actually where the need is the most
and um there was it wasn't a very big
appetite for that before but if you want
to go back to that I'm I'm all I'm all
ears
thank you
I have a couple questions
um
I remember what we went through with the
women's prison it took almost two years
to figure out where it was going to go
we started one then we went to another
and I think we went to a third before we
finally we went back to our ninja one so
the Men's prison have we got any idea
where we're going to put it is it going
to be in a different place yeah so if I
may commissioner Hanks kind of did a
preliminary review of options and I
think she has some good ideas the
initial 10 million I'm putting for it is
to your exact point it takes a year or a
couple years to really figure it out and
then I have 40 million also allocated on
the back end in the second year the
budget to go to put a shovel in the
ground to at least put that marker in
because if you do the study and it just
and even if you figure out exactly where
it's going to go and how big it needs to
be but you have no you can't start
construction at all you just never know
when the next legislature or church will
finally get around to it so I put that
40 million in there to do exactly what
you you're asking deal with the next
couple years of placement I I think
there's I have heard there's a lot of
possibility to keep it right on the same
location which is a huge opportunity but
then you have to look at the size and
the new technologies that would come to
play look at that well you know what the
census is where we think it's going to
go and all that but we have folks online
ready to go if we can allocate some of
the money to do that and commissioner
Hanks I think can give a lot more
perspective she did like a two-page
summary for me about options and that's
where I really got this she said look
this is not 150 200 million dollar
project anymore given inflationary cost
you're at at least 350 if not more
depending on on the size and scope of
this stuff now I think it should still
be run by the state and all that sort of
thing we're not trying to privatize
prisons no no we're just trying to do
exactly what what I think you understand
is the time let's get let's get the ball
rolling and then once we figure out what
we want to do let's put a shovel in the
ground and it kind of commits us to
doing to moving forward I think in the
right way
thank you a comment on inflation what
we've done in the past because we don't
we look at the previous inflation to
judge what we're going to project what
we've done in the past is look at the
two years previous inflation and project
that for the next two years
if we try to
do the second year we have no idea right
there's not much you can go by you know
what you did for last year and the year
before you know what you'll hope forget
next year but two years out
too much guesswork I think that's no I I
completely agree um I I would I mean I I
propose it again I'm trying to keep
everything simple I propose my CPI at a
fixed two percent I just fixed it I mean
that way you're not guessing it just is
kind of built in some years you'll
you'll guess better some years you'll be
a little more on one side and some years
you'll be a little different but again
you can play with that number
um but I would just say that's one of
the reasons why the Delta keeps getting
bigger because we're only technically
you do an average of course but you only
allocate it every other year even though
inflation is a cumulative uh a number so
um however you want to deal with it I'm
wide open I I'm just trying to kind of
hopefully set the marker that if you if
you get something into
built in that it's being accounted for
every year the Delta doesn't grow and
it's not such a battle now again you
guys are gonna have spreadsheet Wars
there's towns that are going to see not
in the next couple years no Town loses
anything in my formula in the next few
years but it may be around year four or
even six or maybe way out in ten yeah
they might start having to adjust
because they just don't have the kids in
their schools like like they used to
um but um but again it gives time for
that that to that to roll out
and another thing that I look at is the
education trust fund Surplus that's
money we can't use anywhere else yeah
and if this current budget gets tight
we're not going to want to have a
surplus in the trust fund that we can't
use where else where we need it so we're
going to try to do something to address
the Surplus
further questions from the committee
representative Stringham and then
represent a leishman uh thank you for
coming it's nice to see you in terms of
targeting the increase where the benefit
would be the most in the Medicaid and
certainly sounds like a great idea uh
figuring out is something else can you
comment though 3.1 percent is a very
specific number and you know I had the
same question how did you why is it not
because that's what the legislature was
proposing I I literally was asking the
team why 3-1 I I can't tell you where
that number came from I apologize I'm
kind of going on with the what the I
think what they're proposing in the
legislature so I just tried to
incorporate that
um
I don't know I I don't know where
exactly they got that number
could have been 4.6 for all I know but
it they I know the legislation that I
was reading said three one so I just
went with that
sometimes you just play the hand you're
Delta I guess but but I'm open for any
flexibility
it sounds like Pi 3.14 yeah wait and
maybe it is maybe it just never that's
their way of never-ending it the dollars
never stop coming in representative
leishman for a question
thank you Mr chairman and uh good
morning morning so how comfortable you
are are you with your Revenue
projections I think my quick
calculations show your budget's up about
1.4 billion over this last
term so how comfortable you are I'm
rejecting Revenue to go down so yeah I
mean what we do is my number comes from
the dra so the draug will give me a low
medium high Revenue projection not just
based on historical but based on all the
other macro economic factors that we
look at in each of the revenue
disciplines right business taxes low
medium high we think it's going to go
here
um tobacco tax we think it's going to go
there Lottery we think it's going to go
there
and then I kind of take uh traditionally
I kind of just take the mid-range
um it always I got to tell you I think
Lindsey stepp and her team are great
because we always end up way under
it always I never not don't have a
surplus so I feel very confident about
those numbers uh going forward at least
for the next couple years yeah without a
doubt I mean if they went if our
revenues drop substantially below a half
a percent
um they I don't think they're going to
in the next couple years if they did
beyond that well now you're talking like
a real severe recession that's you know
in some level which I think we're gonna
have a stagnation I don't know if we're
gonna have a booming recession the other
thing I will lean on a little bit if you
haven't met him
um
my good friend so and so over at um
Unemployment Security who always does
the macroeconomic stuff who am I
thinking of golly Brian Gollum uh over
employment sorry Brian if you're
listening if you're in the room I
apologize Brian is fantastic he looks at
I have Brian look at stuff uh really
from a big picture level I mean he will
look at I'm just going to throw my two
cents into to the work that's being done
over there he'll look at
how many reservations are being made at
open on opentable.com to because that is
a great sign of upper end discretionary
income spending he'll look at the season
passes sometimes on a ski resort because
that looks at the upper and he'll look
at the discretionary spending of
different of different regions and
different uh socioeconomics
placements of demographics to really
figure out where we're going
um he does about a half hour
presentation if you're interested that I
think it just will knock your socks off
he updates the data every month but
combined with his uh Outlook taking a
look at where the revenues where we
think the revenues are going to go where
the changes in the tax structure that we
made a few years ago
being more of a sales factor a tax
structure I really and and we have taken
like a hundred thousand taxpayers off
the rolls right we used to have this we
kind of have a de minimis now we changed
the de minimis for paying your state
taxes uh in terms of business and
profits tax that has simplified
everything by the way the majority of
taxes are paid by the big guys there's
no doubt about that I want to say the 50
top I'm going to get this data point
wrong so I beg people not to completely
quote me but something like the 50 top
taxpayers in the state pay well over 50
of the state's tax right because these
are the big corporate taxpayers they pay
their more than you know that that share
it's huge and there's the diff the
change in dynamics of of businesses you
know how we buy products we buy more on
Amazon so the Amazons are paying them
all we're buying more on you know with
these kind of bigger companies not that
we don't want to keep promoting small
businesses but that reality I think uh
plays into a more uh a better
understanding of where where the these
individual tax brackets will move is
that a James that a safe way of saying
that you think okay there you go so I
feel confident I feel very confident
about it I've always I've always gone it
I've always been a little off to the low
which is a good thing
thank you thank you and thank you Mr
chairman all right representative
McGuire for a quick a question followed
by representative Edwards thank you Mr
chair thank you again
um let me follow up on representative
leishman's question by turning to page
16 in the budget here or the summary
I love that you read this I'm very
excited no it's very good and and your
presentation by the way excellent I hope
we get a copy online so I can share with
constituents and so on yeah
so page 16 you see this is source of
funds and notice that federal funds jump
significantly as do other funds so I
thought this past biennium federal funds
were really way up but we're expecting
this next biennium to be even more is
that true is it where's that coming from
uh yes that's that's that is true that
is uh the agency's uh and departments
projections as the federal revenue that
they are going to be getting uh a lot of
it's coming uh well a lot of it's coming
through HHS that's the main driver of
all of our federal funds and but then
other departments such as uh safety and
Transportation uh are also expecting
large uh Federal Infuse of money as well
if I may yeah arpa is done and all that
like we have a little bit of money to
spend but remember when they reallocated
some of these other bills like
transportation is a great example still
massive I mean they really allocated a
mass amount of money not for this year
but for the next two or three years most
of it will get spent through 26 some
even through 28. so the allocations you
saw that they've already done that's
really what it's based on it's it's a
lot more for everybody Washington yeah
they still have a bit of a spelling
problem but we'll take advantage when
they do and how about the other funds
category there's also another looks like
300 million per year or something going
on
yep so you're looking at the the it's
going from about 1.3 million uh 1.5 this
year and all the way up to 1.6 uh for
the next couple years right
right that's just that's just a variety
of other uh various revenues as the
state collects I mean licenses fees
hunting licenses all of that just a
variety of things yeah that's more
efficient game but uh there's just a
variety of things and when you look at
it the uh what's happening is inflation
is these barely keep up with inflation
so other numbers look like dramatic
increases when you take a uh inflation
of seven percent and eight percent
annually they're really not that's it
thank you
representative Edwards for a question uh
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
another question I'm kind of still on
messaging Governor uh I I I have to
explain this to my constituents and and
so the part that's easy to sell to to at
least to my district is
um uh your commitment to no new taxes no
new fees that's excellent so as I'm
looking at the the budget uh your budget
to us there's there's an exception in
there that I may need some help on and
that's a brand new agency the
prescription drug affordability board uh
it is going to be introducing new
regulation and it's going to introduce a
new fee and uh it it appears to be
redundant with a lot of things that the
department of insurance and others
already do so it's going to be a special
topic that division three looks at but I
just want to make you aware I'm trying
to help you keep your promise no new tax
no new fees the pdab violates that yeah
I did not create that that was created
by the by the legislature like that so
we're just that's was created so we have
to we have to adhere to it I mean if you
want to undo it or change it that's
that's absolutely your prerogative and
that's where I'm going to need some help
is undoing it okay well I can yeah I'll
take a look at it
but I just want people to understand
that's not like something I added into
my budget because I you know I didn't
think of that one in the shower one day
no and I understand it's very
controversial in a challenge so I'm with
you
present a Mooney for a question thank
you Mr chairman thank you Governor thank
you both for being here your ability to
pinpoint all the hot button issues in
the state is spot on in this budget so I
thank you for that just a quick word on
water uh you have a line in there about
Wastewater state aid and is there
anything else you want to add about our
water issues Statewide thank you
Governor well yeah I just I mean uh so a
lot of different opportunities I think
the state has done a phenomenal job in
the past six years on really addressing
clean drinking water uh we made sure
that our problems don't become crises
and that there's a lot of different
funds there's a state revolving fund for
clean drinking water this one for for
Wastewater those have been in existence
for a while by funding those we get a
lot of match Federal opportunity we
still have uh Senator Morse who is not
with us uh well I don't say not put this
anymore he's he's down doing he's out on
the farm he's fine but um but you know
he really did a phenomenal job
um as did the folks at DES in terms of
the clean drinking water fund that was
created out of the the settlement fund
months those go on for quite a while
there's a huge queue of projects they're
all being addressed Bob Scott has done I
think a very in his team have done a
very good job staying right on top of
that
um I mean then you get to I'm just just
so we don't forget we get to everything
from dams you know you get to all the
other water issues and resources and and
flood control and all those sort of
things which I know it's not clean
drinking water driven but actually can
impact clean drinking water issues uh if
they're not if they're not handled
properly so a lot of different funding
sources
um uh yeah I just think uh just we got
to stay right on top of it right and
it's not just a Southern Tier I'll give
Des a lot of credit they made sure that
you know Whitefield had a project moving
Conway has a project I think Conway is a
project yeah those pipes have got one in
the ground about a year ago and it's
really about getting pipes in the ground
I think a lot of these towns have done a
lot of studies we're also updating
helping them update their engineering we
pay for a lot of the engineering
specifically for small towns and I
encourage all these small towns to take
a look the pfast issue is very real it
has to be addressed you know we have our
our standards EPA is trying to push
everybody even way below our standards
which is is problematic and we'll see
where all that pans out federally but we
have very smart standards on clean
drinking water we're building and
designing to them I'll throw this in one
of the real challenges if I may with
clean drinking water which a lot of you
may know and not know
is that you can say hey we have all this
money we're just going to put in pipes
to uh Town X but Town X might not want
pipes people might say look I want my
clean I have a well I want my well
you're going to you contaminated my well
now you got to clean it up so a lot of
citizens don't necessarily want to go on
Town water because then they get a bill
every month into perpetuity and I
totally understand that
um that's one of the local challenges
that some folks are having and why some
of these projects they don't die but
they really slow down Londonderry is a
good example they had a couple good
projects on one side of town there are a
couple neighborhoods that really pushed
back and didn't want the clean drinking
water even though it was really needed
so we're continuing to provide bottles
or whatever it is so
um those local Town Dynamics can be
challenging Des eventually Works them
all out but that's one of the reasons
why sometimes I'll get a call from a
representative well this project isn't
moving forward it's like yeah your town
wouldn't approve it you know because
there's a lot of pushback from the
neighborhood so you got to go work with
those neighbors and listen to them and
try to find a viable solution it's way
more expensive to try to give people you
know clean clean water at the tap as
opposed to just a giant Town Source Town
sources are the best way to give to give
clean drinking water but not always the
most preferred way and and you have to
be you have to understand that a lot of
folks want their own in-house systems
well those come with cost too because
now you need to replace the filters or
the cartridges or the Salter or the
softeners or whatever it is you guys
know how that can all go and to do that
for a thousand different households
every month isn't really practical right
into perpetuity so um yeah there's a lot
of opportunity there I I would just say
keep tapping into each each of these
individual funds whether it's the
settlement funds the local funds or the
federal funds that we get matched out of
that
great excuse me I just want to clarify
an answer I gave you a few uh
representative McGuire on that on those
other funds and it'd be funny that I
didn't remember it
um we are receiving a lot more interest
on our on our savings and uh as our as
our uh surpluses rise and with all the
money we have from arpa that is uh while
it's committed it hasn't been spent
we're earning interest on that so and
that sort of uh included in those
numbers the extra interest that we're
going to get on that knowing the amount
of money but also interest rates have
risen so it's a combination of more
money higher interest rates and that's
in there as well so I'll tell you the
funny story there if I can have 30
seconds so that has never happened
before we always have like rounding
errors of interest and literally at the
very end of the budget process after we
had actually you know really allocated
all the dollars we were talking to the
treasury and she said we didn't realize
this was going to happen but there's
like tens and tens of millions of
dollars of Interest we just I think put
it into the rain day fund on the back
end or something like this because so
there's that's where a lot of the
cushion actually uh came from but yeah
that's that's a big opportunity uh On
Any Given what day what it's February on
every on any given day over the past
year and a half we currently hold about
a billion dollars 1.1 billion more in
cash than we ever have before
um and part of that's arpa is just
strong economy it's a whole variety of
things that create that so if you looked
at our cash flow year over year it's
always cyclical it goes down at certain
times a year and up and then you look at
this year and it's literally a billion
plus we usually have about let's say on
average one and a half one to one and a
half billion but now on average we have
about two and a half billion sitting
there so it was just an inordinate
amount of money
um and cash flow that we had never and
never known to have before so there you
go there's the other there's 60 million
in other funds right there over the
biennium representative Heath for a
question thank you and thank you
governor for taking my question my
question is um with regard to the efas
and I see that um you're increasing them
significantly as well as the eligibility
my question is
um that's a lot of tax dollars
um
my concern I you know I used to work at
the department of Ed and I know the
department of Ed does a fabulous job
overseeing
millions of dollars being dispersed
um I would feel so much more comfortable
if those dollars were being overseen by
the department of Ed I just I struggle
with this much money
um going out through another agency
um that we don't have control over
knowing that the state does such a
powerful job getting funds out with
great accountability I know that you
have few citations in Audits and I would
feel so much more comfortable with it
staying with our state government thank
you for taking well I'll say this last
year we spent about a billion dollars in
education
14 million went to efa's
it's it's it's not
insignificant
it's 14 million out of a billion so it's
still an incredibly incredibly small
piece of the puzzle and I get it you
want to you know we we want to make sure
but the system does have some checks and
balances in place and all that sort of
thing and it's incredibly popular people
want it and it's tax dollars but it's
their tax dollars so and I'll let you
guys I don't get too much into the
politics of it but um it has proven to
be very very popular if you want to put
you know more oversight with with
Department of Education on the program
that would might be a possibility right
and how that comes out I'm all for that
I don't mind that yeah
sure representative Petrie for a
question
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
governor for being here I think it's a
great budget
Stratford County Nursing Home
I didn't see any funds for that uh go
for money R per money uh yeah we give
them 20 million dollars I'm sorry
Stratford Stratford County County yeah
so they uh so the next round of funding
sorry I I apologize I was thinking
Sullivan the next round of funding uh
out of the out of that arpa driven fund
from gopher
I don't know if I have that makes it
soon right
it's very very soon and that's where the
the money will be for Stratford
to the I I need Taylor here to say I but
I think I think they're going to be
happy very good yeah I I really don't
know the exact amount but we did speak
about this at the last executive council
meeting uh and he did I'm just repeating
what he already said publicly the next
round is coming out very shortly
Stratford is one of our maybe the only
one left that has applied for those
funds so I think they're going to get a
pretty a pretty hefty Grant is my
understanding
yeah
representative McGuire for a question
thank you Mr chairman I just had to
respond to this thing about interest
um in my town the trustees of the trust
fund lost fifty thousand dollars this
past year and on investments and when we
asked them about it they said well the
guy we invest with it recommends that we
keep investing so that's what we're
gonna do right so we have to be very
careful no sure and again part of it's
just the interest rates not only do we
have more cash but it's like just the
actual interest rates themselves where
we where we keep our cash you know we do
another thing here um this is a little
bit of an aside but it's an important
point in terms of our Dynamic you have
banks in this state that are slowing
down almost stopping lending because a
lot of banks smaller banks will borrow
from the big Banks right but the rate to
borrow from the big Banks out of Wall
Street is just exorbitantly high so our
smaller banks are slowing down their
lending I'm we've made a push to put
more of our just cash Holdings into the
smaller Banks and I've been working with
the uh the treasurer to do that we did
it one round of it I think we're going
to do another if we're going to be
holding on to a lot of cash well then
our bank should be holding them to a lot
of cash right it helps them lend a
little more so we're trying our best to
use our cash Holdings uh help some of
the Community Banks some of them want to
participate some of them don't for
various reasons but anything we do just
to have them hold our cash so they can
then lend against it I think just helps
I can't help you with your local
decision to go with a guy who keeps
losing you money I don't know so further
questions from committee members
representative Abel
thank you very much thank you governor
for coming uh today I just want to
follow up a little bit more on
representative Mooney's question about
waste water
um I think you know there's a lot of
discussion in the state about landfills
there's also a lot of discussion in the
state about pfas I think we've been
spending an extraordinary money amount
of money and we've needed to on
Wastewater and testing and dealing with
the pfas problem I just wondered if you
could uh share your thoughts with us a
little bit on the front end of the pipe
because of course the things that are
going into our waste water are coming
from sources that include
pfas we just passed a bill in the house
yesterday that will be going to finance
that creates uh currently unfunded Solid
Waste Management fund I'm thinking a lot
about the prior funding of planning
departments within the solid waste
Bureau anything you would want to add I
think that it would be well spent money
to look more at the sources of a lot of
the things we're having to deal with in
our landfills and in our wastewater
treatment plant sure so a couple things
look I I was a I used to design
wastewater treatment plants so like this
is what I believe it or not I used to I
used to say I used to I love this crap
um but I did I was I used to so I really
appreciate what goes in is a huge factor
of what comes out the the cost of I'll
I'm going to add this I'm going to start
with the feds because Lord knows I like
to pick on Washington as much as I can
some of these new rules on wastewater
treatment plants coming from Washington
are really outrageous and I would and I
would caution everybody on that and we
need to push back on that as hard as we
can they're creating rules and systems
um there's a couple of smaller
wastewater treatment plants up north
that um they're just being asked to
basically measure things in a different
way not because they're getting worse
outcomes but by asking them to measure
their outcomes in a different way they
now don't meet these standards that you
know were created for some problem that
was that was happening in Wisconsin
um that's literally happening to us uh
in with a couple small plans and so
we're trying our best to push back on on
the federal side it can be incredibly
costly so I think to your point trying
to manage better what comes into the
system is is always important
um so whether it's cleaning up on me
radiation sites or being Smarter with
um you know just pre-treatment
management I'm all for that of course I
apologize I'm not sure if you're
referencing anything in particular you
know on the pfas stuff we just need
clean drinking water it's there it's a
really really hard thing to get rid of
it's at the level of parts per trillion
not parts per billion or million which
are hard enough as it is
okay well just to just to clarify a
little bit more is uh we have a brand
new Solid Waste Management plan which
hadn't been updated since 2003 and
there's a lot of goals in there to try
better to do better with our Solid Waste
Management in the state it will need
funding I'm not sure what you've put in
your budget but I just really wanted to
take this opportunity to kind of shine a
light on the whole issue I mean
obviously there's a lot of discussion
about maybe having a new landfill in
this state uh the whole trash issue is
really uh big to a lot of people and
pfas is one enormous part of it yeah so
I would look I'm gonna I'm just gonna
you through the softball so I'm just
going to grab it if you don't mind sure
when we talk about landfills I'm going
to throw my two cents in
if we become like other states and say
we're going to solve our landfill issue
by closing landfills and sending our
trash to others to another state well
that's not very environmentally
responsible right that's not doing right
by it either so this idea that we're
just going to close all the landfills
and stop you know
we have actually for what it's worth we
have very good landfills in the state
compared to most States right we really
do
um and I think they we the folks uh Mike
wimsat and the team and the folks at DES
uh do a very good job you know managing
and keeping track of all of that but I
just caution anybody on the landfill
side
um if the answer is well we're just
going to create so many rules and
regulations that you can't build new
landfills here so now we're shipping it
to New York that's not environmentally
responsible that's cowardice that's what
other states do New Jersey does it
Massachusetts does it look at all the
trash we take out of Massachusetts they
want to claim that they're so
environmentally responsible but they
refuse to clean up their own mess and
we're picking we're doing it for them
right I get as frustrated about that as
anybody but the answer isn't we're going
to keep kicking that can and literally
kicking that used can and we're going to
send it to Upstate New York or something
else so we have to be responsible about
that about taking that on and I think
there's an opportunity to do it with the
right regulations and the right
boundaries and all that sort of thing we
do it very well but this idea that we're
just going to be a NIMBY State that's
that's we take care of ourselves in New
Hampshire I think there's a sense of
pride in doing that and doing it smart
and same thing on the wastewater
treatment plants right we don't want to
send our Wastewater somewhere else we
got to take care of it and and do it
right by it so
um yeah I've seen the new Solid Waste
plan it's great
um I had some issues with some of it but
overall it at least gets us you know 20
years ahead of where we were
thank you Governor any any further
questions from committee members
seeing none we thank you for your
immersion in the budget great and your
attention to all the issues that are
circulating in the legislation no you
bet and I'm going to have James and the
team stick around I don't know if you
have any more questions for them but if
you do you know feel free but I'll have
them stick around for a while thank you
please all right
thank you director Edgar for staying
are there any further questions I think
the governor went through most of them
but if there's any further questions
um questions or certainly if you need
looking for any more detail if I don't
have it now I can certainly provide it
uh in a timely manner
question from representative Campbells
thank you thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking the question
um going back to the Men's prison uh is
one of the options is being looked at is
to renovate what's already existing at
maybe 40 50 million dollars versus
breaking ground on a 400 million dollar
new prison
uh I I believe in and certainly the
Department of Corrections uh can can
better answer that question more than me
but my understanding is that the current
prison is in such a state that it will
be cheaper and believe it or not less
expensive to build a new one rather than
try and renovate what they have now
representative Edgar for a question Ed
Edwards for Edgar uh some um Mr Edgar
um we we funded or wanted to fund I'm
having a hard time remembering exactly
what we did the secure forensic hospital
and it's run into some troubles because
we've tried to co-locate it with a New
Hampshire hospital and there's swamp and
ground issues there uh I'm just
wondering if because of the delay should
there be some supplemental money in the
capital or one-time expenditures that
slide that you showed to to to make sure
that we're okay with the secure forensic
Hospital what what are your thoughts uh
first uh overall correction my name is
James Gary g-e-r-r-y so
um
not a problem uh I'm sorry it is
director Edgar our director Gary
director Gary director Gary yeah yes sir
I'll keep practicing until I get it
directly Geary thank you
um for the forensic hospital it was
originally supposed to be completed I
believe uh right around July uh first of
uh 2024. however that's been delayed now
and it's looking like a completion date
of the Fall To December of 2025 which is
outside of this biennium
so
um we we do not have any uh funding in
the budget for for personnel because you
know we don't believe they'll be able to
start hiring until after this biennium
is over however there is flexibility
here whereas if if the construction were
to uh speed up or they would have find a
solution to their problems that they
could come back uh certainly to the
fiscal committee to get funding for
positions they need
follow up so so I wasn't thinking about
the operational money I figured that was
going to work itself out I was really
specifically referring to the delay in
construction and what that may do given
the rates of inflation and supply chain
shortages to whether or not we've
adequately funded the capital side and
whether or not we should be anticipating
a reserve now to make sure that we can
complete the project we aren't aware of
any cost overruns you know as as of now
however uh is anyone familiar with
projects uh especially over this last
few years are concerned is that they
tend to be delayed and come in
overpriced while we have not included
that in in this budget uh that that's
something certainly we could take a look
at
because I mean it would not it wouldn't
shock me and no projects now that comes
in over budget
shouldn't be a surprise
representative Hull for a question thank
you chairman so I'm looking at page
three of the handout that the governor
turned out this morning thank you
um for giving us hard copies so this is
in relative relative to the unrestricted
Revenue at the state level
and we see effectively flat lining
between actual 22 and projected 23
actually there's a decrease of 100
million dollars that then continues into
24 and 25.
and I guess my concern stems around from
where we know we have a 20 or
thereabouts
um
vacancy rate in the various agencies
across the entire department we're going
to do a a significant increase in
salaries for various employees which
will probably as the governor said
increase the number of employees and
decrease the vacancy rate I'm not sure
how the math model Works Beyond 24.25
when you see a significant step in terms
of number of people employed and and
their respective salaries yet the the
revenue to the state is is effectively
flatlined right uh thank you for the
question the answer is is that we what
we've done is uh the the overall pay
increase over the biennium is going to
be roughly 100 million dollars
with most of it coming actually in in
year two uh because you have a
compounding effect from the 10 and the
two percent
and what we've done here is we've
assumed that the positions that we've
added in other words all the funded
positions are funded at the at the new
rates so that's included in this budget
so I guess
um if all of those positions are funded
one of the things that drove these
historically High
um
lapses which left us with so much extra
cash is the fact that the Departments
have such low or such high vacancy rates
right there are a number of open
positions yes if we start the assumption
that we're going to fill all those
positions those lapses won't be there in
the future and how do we manage at that
time write this extra 100 million
dollars per per year in terms of
additional costs with a flatlined
revenue that's correct I'm quickly
looking for the for the lapse numbers
but uh the the lapses over time
especially going to 2425 decrease
so two more historical levels you'll see
uh and I say if I have a few minutes I
can look for it but you you'll see in 23
we have a higher lapse number because of
the high vacancy rate and that number
drops dramatically for 24 and 25
assuming that we're going to fill these
positions okay thank you you're welcome
representative waller for a question
the chairman Weiler and thank you for
being here Mr Gary
um one thing you hear a lot about in the
news
is the need for child care
and it affects employers and affects
families and it affects providers we're
trying to provide the service and I
wonder if there's any initiatives in the
budget
to start to address some of the child
care concerns
um
for that I'm going to have to uh I will
research that and get back to you
for that information there there is
money in here I just don't have those
numbers off the top of my head
great thank you I would really
appreciate that thank you
representative McGuire for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you director
Gary
um I want to follow up on representative
Hull's question so he referred you to
page three in today's handout that's the
same as page 15 in the big document or
the green document
but page 16 of the green document
doesn't seem to match page 15. so
um specifically if you look at the sum
of general fund and education fund on
page 16 the numbers are quite different
than the ones on page 15 and maybe this
is something you'd have to research but
I'm wondering why why don't they sort of
match up if you look for example at
actual fiscal 22 general fund 1.6
education fund 1.1 the sum is
2.7 or something but over here it's 3.2
you see what I mean all right well on on
page on page 15 you're looking at a
combined General and education fund yes
right
but go to 16. actual see general fund
1.6
and see education fund 1.1
you add those two up you get 2.7
that's not
that's way off from 3.2
I'm guessing that's a research question
but no if you
uh for fiscal year what what year are
you looking at actual fiscal year 22.
okay fiscal your actual 22 uh
three point two
billion
and
well because
this is this is specific specific funds
and so for the for the education and uh
General funds you'd be you would include
some of the liquor money
um
as well into that I believe so that may
be the difference see I don't think so
because in the recommended so as you go
further along they get closer and closer
that calculation so okay there's
something weird about 22 and 23 compared
to 24 and 25. okay I can I can research
that and get back to you that's not a
problem
there were a couple of things that I
noticed in recent handouts that we've
had
uh from various divisions and committees
one of them was the surprise that the
list of uh employees seem to be fairly
steady across
several years and we keep hearing about
all these vacancies but they don't seem
to be listed at the what the list I
looked at seemed to show
quite a level number of employees
another piece that I looked at was from
the retirement system and it showed the
number of people leaving the retirement
system the surprise to me was those with
less than a year the leaving was 25
percent
it seems to me we may have a problem not
only with are we hiring the right people
or why aren't we retaining them is it a
hostile work environment and I've heard
that testimony from a person that it is
a hostile work environment so that's
something that
ought to be brought to the governor's
attention so that he could share with
the other Commissioners and directors
that looking at data like that 25
percent are leaving in their first year
kind of shocking
um something needs to be done about it
and the fact that we have this big
turnover and maybe that's why the number
of employees if you're listing four
people in the same job
one leaving every quarter maybe it looks
like more employees but
representative McGuire you wanted to
comment on that yes I have somewhat of
an answer because I have a bill related
to exactly this being heard at two
o'clock today in Edna so so there's
there's two sets of figures here in
terms of how many people quit one is
what does the retirement system assume
which is the 25
and then and then 18 and so on there's a
list that's what they assume from their
I don't know books or something but then
there's the actual experience so there
was there's a table of they did a study
from 2016 to 2019 and and it's very
little in the first year maybe two or
three percent and then the second year
is more like 11 and then 11 and then so
it's so the actual experience study
compared to what the retirement system
assumes there's a big disconnect there
um especially in the early years so
that's an assumption rather than a fact
exactly and but
there's also very in the different
categories that the retirement system
has uh standard employees teachers
police and fire there's very different
experience that funnel of sort of how
many people you hire and then the next
year those there's some quit and then
the next year some quit and so on down
to the end are different shapes for
those different categories of employees
anyways it's very interesting subject
but I can show you some tables
um I'll be there it's not really 25 yeah
go to Edna at two o'clock
per the questions from director gear for
director Geary
represent representative papavichi
Mueller thank you Mr chair and thank you
director for taking the question I'm I'm
not sure if it's a policy question or a
budget question or we were talking
earlier about landfill space and one
Associated issue that the town of
Windham is struggling with is that right
now it costs us more to dispose of
recyclables that it costs us to dispose
of trash now part of what I was told is
that it's because of the policies of the
state of Massachusetts where we
apparently have to move our stuff but
is that something that
would make sense to you know look at is
the state you know from the governor's
office
policies suggestions on how to handle
those things because honestly it kind of
doesn't make sense that you have to pay
more to dispose of recyclables after
you've done all the work of separating
them
then you you know pay to dispose of
trash where you just put it into you
know a bag so I just as I said I don't
know if it's an appropriate question for
you but since the topic came up I
figured no harm in asking yeah I I think
it is a policy question and it's a very
good question I think is one that that
needs to be looked at uh as the governor
said so long as we're not shipping it to
New York we're you know and taking care
of it ourselves so we're always looking
for the the best way and the most uh
financially feasible way to to to solve
this problem and if uh if if you uh or
or any of your uh
um fellow Representatives have have
ideas on how to do that we'd love to
listen thank you I was looking to listen
to yours but I appreciate that it's our
job thank you
represent Petrie for a question
yeah thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here uh the uh uh yeah the
retirement system liability
have you done any numbers to say if we
put uh and it's I believe it's funded at
around 65 percent is there any table
where if you put 50 million it would
bring it up to 75 percent if you've done
any work on that at all uh I I have not
and and we have not uh we we have relied
on the retirement system uh for for
their numbers and we've worked with them
and uh you know we'll continue to do
that but we have not done that
you want to say something sir
representative leishman
thank you Mr chairman uh addressing
representative Petrie's question we'll
have that information on Thursday we're
meeting with the Retirement Board
thanks
representative erf thank you Mr chair
could you make your electronic version
of the slides available to the LBA for
publishing for us absolutely thank you
director Geary do we have a phone number
where we can contact you
uh yes you may it's 603-714-8651
representative education
thank you
um
so this is kind of a follow-up to a
question I was asking the governor
um and that is that as you look at the
budget he's able to show where we're
investing well he's able to show where
there's a tax that we might cut
there's nothing in this budget that I
can see for that we're targeting as Bill
payers for some of the things that we
know we need to spend more money on such
as salaries you know let's let's let's
assume that the Medicaid rate of 3.1 is
probably too low for where we're really
at is there a list of Bill payers
programs that the governor might
anticipate needs actually fewer
resources than what he's asked for
is there like a double secret list
somewhere where we can go and see where
the priorities are to reduce spending if
we had to
uh we we have not had we did if if that
list exists uh it is so secret that I
have not been privy to it
um what uh the the advantage of this
budget is we've sort of been dealing
from a position of strength and you're
right spending does increase and it
increases roughly 11 12 over the
biennium uh which is pretty much right
alongside of inflation and in addition
to that what we've done in this budget
is we've been playing catch-up uh in the
last biennium we had a lot of spending
cuts we moved a lot of agencies off of
general fund revenues and and put them
on to specialized Revenue sources which
are being drained uh one example is
there's the highway fund and uh with the
the money going there uh on the last
budget the legislature paraded 50
million dollars a general fund just to
keep the highway funds solvent uh we've
seen Fish and Game sort of China you
know drawing down on on on their
revenues and so what we've done is a put
back some of the spending cuts we did
through the biennium through covid and
then number two we've moved agencies and
departments off of their specialized
funds which have a limited life back to
the general fund which is why you see
the increase there
um if certainly if if revenues don't
come in as projected uh if uh we need
there is some sort of event in the world
that uh you know causes a severe
recession in the state and we need to to
cut back on programs we can come up with
that list really quick
uh director Gary I was I'm just tempted
to say you know if you want to share it
with me sooner rather than later that
way we can prepare for the end of the
world together so all right thank you
thank you
some of the things I observe when we do
a big pay raise
usually it goes on the anniversary date
of their hiring or some anniversary date
or promotion or something are we
following along with that in the
agreement I don't have any
any word of the agreement you might and
if so
how will it spread out is there an ideas
likely not even leave across every state
every month rather for this increase and
also
the one that's making a hundred thousand
is going to get twice as much of of a
pay raise if we do ten percent than the
one who's making fifty thousand is there
any realization within the contract on
that yeah there's not and that this
works like like a typical uh
pay raise one that's been bargained with
the Union would do so what happens is is
that the 10 percent becomes effective on
this July 1st July 1st 2023 uh across
the board to every state worker uh
following that on July 1st 2024 will be
an additional two percent so it doesn't
it's not phased in on their anniversary
dates or their higher dates it's it's
everyone will receive a pay increase on
July 1st 2023 of 10 we need to do that
we need to know that when we're doing
the budget
further uh thank you and this is just a
follow-up to your question
representative Wilder and that is on I
was listening to the governor on Drew
Klein this morning and the question was
asked who who would be subject to
receiving the 10 percent and I I think
on the radio he said everyone that he is
in a position to negotiate the union
contracts with and at the point he
didn't know and he wasn't willing to say
because he wasn't sure whether it meant
the other employees that are not under
Union contracts could you could you
clarify if it truly is all employees
regardless of whether or not they're
under a contract it is all employees
thank you
further questions from director for
director Geary
I don't see any
thank you for your expertise we'll be in
touch thank you and thank you for having
me greatly appreciate it
any of the other folks want to make any
comment
I'll just say on the HHS question for
the 3.1 percent
um that was proposed by HHS
um so that's where that number came from
thank you for the answer
right members I believe we have some
divisions starting at one o'clock to
work on on the budget sections and uh
we will now
a good time to break for lunch thank you
thank you for your attendance
so division three we're done for the day
unless you want to do some homework
and those of you that are on the fiscal
committee for Friday will have a
pre-fiscal at nine o'clock on Friday
foreign